[Music]
it was the first visit by an iranian
president qatar in a decade
ibrahim raisi's arrival to doha on
monday was also his first trip to a gulf
country since becoming president
whilst doha and tehran have strengthened
their bilateral relations in recent
years iran has found itself
diplomatically and even militarily at
odds with other gulf countries
particularly saudi arabia and the united
arab emirates but in a sign of a
possible shift in regional diplomacy
president raisi stressed his keenness to
improve ties with other gulf corporation
council members
the united states should prove its will
to lift sanctions in order to achieve an
agreement for the nation's benefit
guarantees and closing down of all
political dossiers are of vital
importance our region has entered a new
era after decades of the presence of
occupying forces the region is going
back to its original owners
a number of bilateral deals and
agreements were signed during the visit
but most significant was the messaging
from both leaders qatar's emir
clearly his country's interest in the
restoration of the iranian nuclear deal
we have been briefed regarding the
vienna talks on the agreements between
iran and the west and this matter is
quite important and has a lot of impact
on the stability of the region qatar is
following the negotiations with lot of
interest and we hope that very soon an
agreement could be reached it will
benefit all parties by guaranteeing
rights of all countries to use nuclear
power according to international laws
and agreements
among the other topics discussed by the
two leaders was the developments in
afghanistan with both men highlighting
the need for an inclusive government
there
palestine too is where iran and qatar
find the shared interest
the palestinian cause was also discussed
it is the central issue of our region we
stressed on the immediate need of ending
israeli attacks on the palestinian
people we talked about sorting out the
matter according to international law so
that palestinians are treated fairly and
they can live in stability qatari
diplomacy has witnessed a number of
major successes in recent months
furthering the country's brand as a
mediator and key force in conflict
resolution
whilst iran currently finds itself
embroiled in a number of diplomatic and
military conflicts of its own
from the war in yemen to the standoff
over its nuclear programme the hope is
that stronger qatari iranian relations
will help resolve at least one of those
conflicts
jamal shayal al-jazeera